("The Beautiful Blue Danube Waltz" begins)
- [Amanda] It's pretty
cool to be able to be part
of something so big.
We are making the next generation
of human space flight possible every day.
I'm Amanda Gertjejansen,
and we're in New Orleans at
Michoud Assembly Facility,
and we're developing the technology
to put a man on Mars.
(waltz continues)
- [Announcer] We have a liftoff.
Liftoff on Apollo 11.
- [Amanda] Boeing was a
part of the Apollo days,
we were part of shuttle,
and now it's Space Launch System.
- [Chad] SLS is the world's
biggest, most powerful
human-rated rocket ever to be built.
Our current mission is to take astronauts
deeper into space than ever before.
And this SLS vehicle is the platform
that we will do that with.
I'm Chad Bryant.
I'm the NASA Core Stage Manager for SLS.
The Core Stage is the
central piece of the rocket.
It contains oxygen and
hydrogen that mixes together
to form a very explosive combustion,
two million pounds of thrust,
that gets it off the pad
and deeper into space
than ever before.
Going to Mars is not easy,
and so it requires a lot of detail
in the design of the rocket.
It's all got to work together perfectly
in order to execute the mission.
We have human lives at stake.
All it takes is one part to fail,
and we can lose the mission.
You can't do anything of this scale
without tremendous amount of teamwork.
- [Amanda] Like, it's basically
like this whole dance,
and we're the dance conductor.
You're excited to come to work everyday
because you're part of
developing the technology
to put a man on Mars,
which would be an ultimate new frontier.